après 45 ans passés dans un village
breton un ancien prisonnier de guerre
allemand fait don de sa terre à la
commune où il a rencontré la nuit des
centaines japon caraquet
non
où
[Musique]
hulu
pour
où
[Musique]
m'avait la lie j'ai 72 ans et joue les
jantes montmagny
je m'appelle alphonse à ceux ci 73 ans
je suis née en plus horizontale et je
suis en faire plus en également venus en
france
[Musique]
vous
avaient été faits prisonniers par des
forces alliées en allemagne car la
pression je me suis retrouvé à l'hôpital
et en plus parler parfait allié
de là ils nous ont vite aux autorités
françaises et par 30 coups sont venus
discale est née dans un camp qui
s'appelle de 30 milles 102 et qui se
trouvaient à st jacques deray main nous
sommes venus après une quinzaine de
jours ou trois semaines verra forcément
sa maman et partager un petit commando
que les uns à sa levée aux villes ou
villages pour l'entretien et d'autres
commando pour l'agriculture comme
j'étais déjà allé culteurs je suis amer
dans une ferme où les gens étaient très
compréhensible et où il y avait moins
adroit il y avait aussi à la ferme de
deux filles et un garçon puis il était
très gentil avec moi
cette jeune fille c'était qui cette
jeune fille elle est akbar à côté de
brad pitt 45 à côté de moi
racontez-moi anigo moment comment vous
l'avez connu vous vous souvenez quand je
les ai vus la première fois j'ai des
parents le soir il m'a fait pitié
tellement il était maigre c'est comme ça
que ça a commencé d'abord par la pitié
et puis
ensuite les deux eu vraiment amis
je la connais très bien nous sommes des
amis d'enfance nous allions à l'école
ensemble à l'école qui est d'ailleurs
tout près ici sainte catherine et nous
sommes restés toujours très amis mais
enfin je crois que c'est à l'arrivée de
alphonse qu'il ya eu un petit un petit
froid parce que évidemment à l'époque
nous n'étions pas très chaud vous savez
la population d'ailleurs a très mal vu
sonam les haleurs allons en disant parce
que les gens qui avaient souffert de la
guerre soit par l'occupation soit par un
membre de leur famille qui ont été tués
ou prisonniers évidemment il était anti
allemand disons on perd les faits la
guerre de 14 18 alors il l'aimait
beaucoup en france mais pour un gendre
c'était pour ça ça ne pensais pas et
puis un jour tout de même y au bout d'un
certain temps d'abord on avait l'âge de
on était majeure je lui avais parlé
sérieusement alors il s'est décidé il
m'a dit maintenant est-ce que c'est
alphonse mais il sera mon gendre mais
que personne ne vienne me dire de mal de
dos des mariages à la mairie à cette
pratique comme déclaration sur la rue
est arrêté des croix gammées aux
fenêtres de la mairie des ciseaux des
les gens avec des figures heures plus
tôt au style me souviens de son mariage
me souviens l'avoir vu
et semble les avoir vus descendre en
bicyclette en tenue de travail pour
détourner l'attention des gens
d'autant plus que ce jour là il y avait
une distribution de tickets
d'alimentation à la mairie parce que les
ti-cats existait toujours
le lendemain du mariage à la mairie mon
frère est allé pour voir un petit peu
dans sa lunette dans la rue des écoles
donc la rue du commando il y avait des
gens de chaque côté qui nous attendait
pour nous voir pensez sûrement pas pour
nous féliciter le nom qu'on lui passait
en vélo ou qui leur a rien dit les
joyeux au bout d'un moment et ce sans
fatigue est là sans doute si third party
et vous vous êtes mariés quand elle
avant l'église
le 28 juin à quelles heures 5 heures du
matin comme ça personne le connaissant
vous aviez l'impression que le village
vous traitez comme il aurait traité ces
femmes que l'abonné sur wii
et puis chacun je crois que entre les
gens se sentent rennais si vous voulez
ce peut-être qu'il y en aurait qui
n'aurait pas osé aller mais alors je
suppose que leur disais je viens de voir
viens de voir est qu'est ce qu'ils
auraient pu faire vous croyez ce qu'ils
voulaient je pense rien c'était pour
nous intimider nous faire peur je pense
qu'on a eu des lettres de menaces avant
le mariage
plusieurs hommes n'a jamais réuni la
famille quand même un peu plus
intelligent de deux ans pour s'asseoir
les rumeurs disaient jusqu'à des
convives est pas par semaine c'était
mauvais on ne veut pas alors vous allez
à la plage elle ouvertement devant tout
le monde est une fête
certes on travaille là
regardez
[Musique]
vous vous n'avez jamais eu envie de
retourner en allemagne
non non parce que j'ai réalisé que je
vécus et donc ici la descente écouler ce
psy adopté ou piller les légendes et
pillé adaptées aussi plus souvent au
début bien sûr mais à la longue ça c'est
bien dommage et rien depuis quelques
années en fait que ça fait quand même
bien si je pouvais arriver là a laissé
quelque chose ou donner quelque chose à
la va vite de son honneur comme comparer
merci mon d'avoir été acceptée d'abord
et ensuite elle aura vécu comme souvent
moeurs et pour des raisons tête dans les
mains
aujourd'hui il ya plus autant il
serpente dans millions parce que pour
nous
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
tous les deux tout s'est étendu de vingt
ans c'était dommage de laisser c'était
tellement jolie elena vanessa ne pouvait
faire que ça puisque la commune qui
pourrait s'occuper de sa fine et
toujours qu'est ce qu'on ferait bien la
balle et il fait sens très bien dans la
ligue 6 alors elle soit je suis libéral
a commis s'était vu arriver il d'avoir
des lakers qui a encore des moments
cette bande à rien je vais avoir proposé
quelque chose à vous sera posée dans
cette rebelle à l'est était tombé du
ciel
est ce qu'ils vont faire des rondes sa
portée prévisions annoncent une nouvelle
année sans que ça fasse plaisir à tout
le monde ici sa charmante son fameux
c'était que sa reconnaissance des
appareils
à mi temps qu'il a passé s'il savait
l'épongé a été passé ils sont très très
estimé monsieur renaud ayant été très
très brave homme qui l'un d'eux de
qualité
[Musique]
la joie de 45 ans le mariage le 23 juin
disant invités à repérer pour signer
définitivement cette tentation d'un
délicat
et par la même occasion du bord
c'était comment
et toi
qu'est ce qui compte le plus pour vous
êtes citoyen ces honneurs
on alors je ne devrais pas pour chercher
pas du tout militaire aux citoyens de
saguenay
et actuellement ceux-ci n'ont même pas
très fiable dernière
on verra
[Musique]